avez vous déjà fait par le passé quelque
chose qu'ils vont regretter amèrement
actuellement comme faire tomber cet
objet et bien moi oui et encore mieux il
s'agissait de vidéos sponsorisées vos
vidéos préférées finalement les gens se
plaignent encore beaucoup d youtuber qui
travaillent avec les marques
alors oui les foi de données vidéo de
mer mais deux fois c'est dans des trucs
cool et aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer
ce que ça donne quand ça donne des
vidéos de merde vous avez peut-être déjà
vu ce que je vous montre elle a en tout
cas sachez que pendant des années les
gens se sont amèrement moquer de moi
dans le youtube games pour avoir osé
participer à ces choses c'est parti la
vidéo de la honte la première attention
ça s'appelle clash food c'est une série
de vidéos sponsorisées fois j'avais
touché 500 euros à savoir puisqu'il
fallait pour acheter une xbox menaces
assorties ou une ps4 plus un appartement
je sais pas regardez on l'a on l'a tous
fait on est tous des grosses merdes
parce que je me dis mais je me dis quand
même les gens qui l'ont fait après moi
dans le doute
a new titeuf votre cas prod seb la frite
remember les gars remember on va
regarder un peu ensemble parce que chez
vous avez envie d'être d'être très mal à
l'aise et après je vous explique
pourquoi je me suis fait douillet moi
c'était contre dark funeral c'est parti
l'usiné râle bienvenue dans clash food
l'émission qui clash et qui food ouais
je te lâcher c'est vrai ça fait mal ça
brûle sa boule l'intestin et pour une
fois c'est pas coca qui brûle c'est la
otages étaient bien bien plus haut on
dit de lui que c'est le gamer le plus
tard et en cuisine
rien ne l'arrête voici squeeze
c'est sûr jouer c'est nul c'est horrible
tu vas devoir cuisiner une pizza trash
au chèvre pour ton pote d'arc funèbres
et va bien manger fut pas mais n'en dit
pas si longtemps car on bat infligé un
handicap cher squeeze d'accord et oui
sinon ça serait trop facile
vous sentez la douille arriver là à vous
expliquer un père m'avait dit que
j'allais faire une vidéo originale avec
un youtuber de mon choix tout en étant
payé pour ça j'étais content je me
disais ouais mais on va faire quoi
exactement il m'avait dit bah tu vas
devoir cuisiner dans les circonstances
rigolote par exemple tu adore cuisiner
du poisson au milieu d'une horde de
chats qui sont donc pourquoi tu y es
parce que tu cuisines c'est la pratique
mais convaincu je m'en souviens vous
gasté à trois heures je soutiens
totalement
j'ai donc accepté en me disant [ __ ] ça
va être hyper marrant on va trop
s'amuser ça va être original cool ouvrez
bien vos narines faut se fera sentir là
d'où je suis un mec gentil
oui eh bien tu va cuisiner avec ton
visage aaa
voilà je ne savais état final non plus
ne savais pas que nous allions devoir
cuisiner avec notre visage maintenant on
a pesé mais sûr j'aimerais silence
complet pour faire place au moment le
plus ma maison de l'histoire ce match et
nuit
à aden décennies d'état bravo les amis
bravo grâce à vous ce fils de [ __ ] a
maintenant 7 millions d'abonnés bravo
bravo al dente sinoti supportable vous
trouvez may cry et ma voix qui mue
constamment insupportable mais le
squeeze de cette vidéo est cent fois
pire plus tard et ça ça ruine par dark
funeral qui goûte ma pizza voit très
bien très bien très bien très bien très
bien
j'avais bien pouces bleus ces bons
ailiers c'est sur faut vraiment gênant
mais j'insiste ce qu'ils regardent en
2015 lève la main ce n'est pas pierre
serais pas fier bcbc l'a vraiment bas
votre bon rip à tous ceux qui l'ont fait
derrière en sachant ce que c'était légal
vous pardonnerai jamais à toi ya
beaucoup de sable à frites sur cette
chaîne 1 à ça mais faire la vidéo de
qualité un serbe
c'est maintenant l'heure du deuxième
truc que je regrette le plus au monde à
moi avant que la chaude on avait été
contacté pour tourner une sorte de deux
mythes de mini court métrage de
plusieurs épisodes où c'était une
parodie de splash l'émission de tf1 soit
pareil on était payé j'avais touché je
crois milo rau que c'était énorme
moi j'étais encore à au lycée monge été
refait en plus je voyais surtout ça
comme un projet coût des vidéos
marrantes qui change un peu de ce qu'on
fait d'habitude
abbas a changé ouest et de la berd au va
regarder qui est là jérémy tu es content
d'être dans cette vidéo où j'ai le mieux
tu peux parler des regrets vas-y vas-y
cesser at war asie
déjà juste avec sujet d'eric tu sais tu
aurais dû cliquer sur autre chose
bon je vais juste vous être mon passage
parce que ça qui nous intéresse mais en
gros c'était à concours de plein il
fallait faire le plus beau plein
possible et comme c'était ya trois ans
ce que ce corps que vous traiter de
lâche
bah ya trois ans c'était un corps de
traître un corps de haute trahison mon
gars c'est douloureux c'est ou l'autre
tout le monde sait squeeze ou plutôt du
cac et d'habitude j'aime bien sûr des
peut-être des vidéos sur les jeux dans
lesquels je dit beaucoup de conneries
vraiment naze aujourd'hui je vais devoir
relever un challenge vraiment très très
important 2 je suis pas du tout à l'aise
là c'est scandaleux ce qui se passe à la
piscine savez vous plus tôt des maladies
style mycoses verrues des trucs qui fut
en fait je sais dans l'eau je revendique
cette blague pour moi la piscine c'est
un lieu dans lequel il est possible de
rencontrer d'autres l'eponge mais
malheureusement je revendique cette
blague lorsque tu connais le principe tu
connais le principe faut affronter ses
peurs et faire le plus grand plouf
1 tu t'éclates à faire des vidéos sur le
net attends c'est drôle que tu vas
t'éclater ok t'es prêt tu l'as tu as
fait tes preuves
tu connais ça allait du coup si on y va
aller
on devrait quand même promis dans le
contrat doit sauter des nos phobies qui
a en dira courte été content de passer
dans ma vidéo du mort assez du lot et
comme tu veux comédien lecteur puisse
dire est ton plat ça nous fera très
bonne et due forme quattro a acheté sa
carte à jouer aux jeux vidéo blague
revendiquée par seb la frite
[Musique]
ah [ __ ] mec c'est tellement des
regrets et non mais je vous jure que
l'on m'a trop les pendant longtemps
pendant très longtemps à l'essai lors du
dernier regret ah parce que jamais deux
sans trois ça c'est dur ça c'est dur ça
c'est une parodie des anges de la télé
réalité mais encore plus nul que le vrai
programme et de latéralité qui est déjà
bien nul à chier donc ces trois mois
après que la chaude as tu es une grosse
année 2013 ça y allait on était présent
de quoi y avait une villa et j'ai pu y
avait un scénario tout claquer mon gars
y avait bien des épisodes et chaque
épisode suivait le point de vue d'une
personne différente qui va regarder ça
de la frite et à la coupe de justin
bieber à l'époque tirer la chasse la ses
tigres a pas tiré la chasse c'est ita
pas tirer la chasse ou s'est-il caf a
tiré la chasse est à peine ça commence
et c'est déjà nul
c'est incroyable je passe devant les
toilettes et comme d'habitude la chasse
d'eau qu'est pas tirer mais franchement
c'est trop dégueu couach et sur ses
toits squeeze mais parce que c'est toi
t'as pas tirer la chasse pourquoi tu
assumes pas là je te dirais
ma petite kelly je les tire une chose
moi voilà c'était mon rôle dans cette
vidéo je jouais le pervers de la vidéo à
présent je vais caché derrière ses
lunettes dernière génération se tire pas
la chasse à simenon
mais ce que c'est moins métadier la
chasse ou pas et l'avoir tech sa console
elle transforme au hacking diggle oit le
scénario alors là alors l'homme appelle
hollywood oui allô oui on a un scénario
hors du commun la console s'est
rassemblée en gagnent pas 500 combien
diminuer le budget mais c'est ça je te
lâche pas trop chaud dans tiny se voir
tête normal nous tirent dessus
grece bordel oscarisée en 2014 frère le
core 2 qui dit hélas là il se désintègre
en particules dans l'air comme ça c'est
mes romans de la vidéo on voit avoir
quelqu un parti en particulier la même
la vidéo pourrait partir à particules
mois ce qui ferait un bon père mère et
anna est devant moi en sous-vêtement
comme ça et là je me retrouve et qui je
vois oscarisée en 2015 une seule idée en
tête je propose qu'on parte en beauté on
se maquille trois complices c'est une
pierre ses caisses le pire le pire c'est
qu'elle joue mieux que moi avec la
meilleure actrice
ça fait pas ça
oups je me suis tiré dessus faudrait
peut-être qu'on m'apprenne à tirer du
bon sens un bon ok je tiens ce que
l'avenir coûtait c'est moi qui ai nam
c'est moi qui parle oui d'accord mais
bordel oui mais franchement mon honneur
et je me retrouve avec un canard dans la
main alors à vous annulez la production
des films à cette vanne vous a pas
convaincu stars fall away
voilà c'était les plus grandes erreurs
de ma carrière de youtube heures si vous
saviez comme ça m'a hanté pendant
longtemps a participé à ces trucs là
parce que en fait c'est toujours dur de
te projeter dans une vidéo quand tu as
juste à un script ou même des fois juste
une phrase comme l'histoire de des chats
et du poisson là alors qu'ambri la vidéo
c'était pas du tout ça voilà je
m'exprimerai dooya mais là j'avais le
scénario je savais ce que c'était que
c'était j'ai quand même accepté et j'ai
tellement mal fait j'ai très très
content quand j'étais jeune donc je m'en
veux pas voilà on a tous fait des
erreurs à noël sont las de la friterie
donc si vous êtes sur youtube peu
importe depuis combien de jours année
semaines ou mois gens ne m'en fous
réfléchissez bien à ce que vous faites
n'acceptait pas des choses par politesse
osé dire non à la toile une vidéo grâce
d'avoir gardé par des mots bien c'était
mes erreurs de youtube à kyoto en pis
[Musique]